but you have not commented on how
ridiculous that I'm dressed you know
what I was gonna say but you know what I
gotta be honest with you dude I'm a kid
that likes a comfortable sweatshirt that
thing looks amazing can I tell you when
I bought this thing dude I was coming
down off of mushrooms and I'm like oh
that looks so soft
I'm watching you in it now and I'm going
dude that looks like it falls on you
song dude I'm telling you right now if I
was the youngest single man you walk
around something like this they want to
snuggle with you but that's one for the
younger fellas out there if you've got
no game put on some soft clothes dude if
I was your girlfriend I'd sleep in that
there you go a hundred percent
100.